hi there today we're going to look at
mastering atari games with limited data
by
yeah
hua liu tanahar kurotouch pietrabil and
yang gao this paper presents the
efficient xero model which is a model
that can do reinforcement learning with
severely limited data
so the paper tackles the atari 100k
benchmark which means to learn atari the
atari benchmark as a reinforcement
learning task as for example deep q
networks did but you only get 100k
transitions uh this is about it's about
two days worth of real time data to work
with and after that the models
supposedly be able to play atari so this
is a variant on mu0 mu0 which is an
insanely data intensive reinforcement
learning algorithm and it introduces
various tricks and various amendments to
mu0 to make it more sample efficient
so when we look at this paper you can
see the gist of it right here uh if you
do this atari 100k benchmark you can see
that a lot of the other reinforcement
learning algorithm they fail to even
reach human level performance whereas
this new algorithm out competes not only
the other rl algorithms on in this low
data regime but also the humans here
they say
efficient zeros performance is close to
dqn's performance at 200 million frames
while we consume 500 times less data
efficient zeros low sample complexity
and high performance can bring rl closer
to real world applicability
they even say we implement our algorithm
in an easy to understand manner and it
is available at this github address so
this code is out there especially if you
want to do reinforcement learning but
you don't have as much compute or time
or money
this might be for you
so we'll go through the paper we'll see
what the improvements are there's not a
single improvement there are many
improvements uh three big ones to be
exact
and yeah if you like content like this
don't hesitate to subscribe
and and and tell your friends and family
and
professors
i guess
all right so
uh we'll first take a small look at what
mu0 does just as a recap i have done a
video on mu0
but if you haven't seen that then here
is a short a very short uh introduction
to mute zero to the algorithm so in a
classic reinforcement learning setting
you have your your basic setup of you
have the environment
and you have the actor
and the environment gives the actor some
sort of an observation at time step
let's call it t
um
the actor
uses that observation to come up with
some sort of an action at time step t
and then the environment gives the actor
back a reward
for that time step and the next
observation t plus one and that goes on
and on and on so the question is how is
the actor supposed to come up with this
action right here given the past
observations that it has seen from the
environment in order to maximize all of
the reward that it gets
now in a regular reinforcement learning
algorithm or regular let's say in the
simpler reinforcement learning algorithm
what people are doing is they're doing
model-free reinforcement learning which
essentially means that they take the
series of observation observation one
observation two and so on that they've
seen so far they take that they stick it
in a big neural network and they train
it to output some sort of an action
and they train the neural network in
order to maximize this reward right here
usually using some sort of policy
gradient or something like this so this
is a rather rather direct way we call
that model-free reinforcement learning
because you directly predict the action
without
without an explicit model of the world
now when you have a model of the world
so when this environment here is well
described for example a chess board in a
chess board you know the rules you know
everything that's going to happen in a
chess board you can use a model of the
chessboard
so what you can do is this you can take
these observations
and these observations would correspond
to some defined state or let's let's say
tic-tac-toe tic-tac-toe is a better
example so
you know with the observation i can
actually construct the board of
tic-tac-toe that i'm in and then what i
can do is i can actually search so i can
try out i can say okay what if i put you
know something here oh then my
opponent's certainly gonna do that right
here and then what if i put something
here and then my opponent is gonna do
that and then they win right so
that is one
that is one way to do it and usually you
visualize this as a tree so you are here
at a root note that's your state and you
have several options to do things and in
these several options your opponent has
several options or if it's a one player
game you have several options again and
so on so what you want to do is you want
to search this tree for the best
possible
path and this is what things like
alphago alpha zero and so on did
they have this explicit model and they
search through it and now the neural
networks no longer predict actions
directly the neural network help you
search through that tree which means
they they
vote essentially on which par paths of
the tree to explore because the tree
quickly becomes too large to explore as
a whole right you can't like if it's
more than three moves ahead the
possibilities just
get giant even like especially in a game
like go
so the neural networks are here to guide
the tree search and that was
in general the techniques of that center
around the monte carlo tree search
because at some point you abort the
search and you simply play one game to
the end as sort of an approximation of
what happens um and so on i'm not
going to go into that super duper right
here but what mu zero does is mu0 says
well this this whole three search stuff
essentially only works if i have an
explicit model of the world such as the
tic tac toe board it's clearly defined
how it works right also i can i can i
can have a simulator for it i can rewind
i can try again
this doesn't happen when you're
interacting with any sort of
real world thing let's say or even the
atari benchmark so in atari i know there
is there's hacks where you can save the
rom and so on but essentially you're not
supposed to go back in time or go
forward in time you're not supposed to
be able to try something out and then
say well
no that didn't work i'm going to search
for a different path in the tree instead
so what people do is
they
they try to learn a model of the
environment so in absence of the model
of the environment they try to learn one
and there are
many many different ways of doing this
and what mu zero does is it learns a
latent model of the environment
so how does that look so here you have
the current observation observation t
what mu zero does is it uses a neural
network i think they call this h or
something
to get this into a hidden state
so
they map the current observation into a
hidden state
and then they plan
using the hidden state so
they plan they say okay
i'm not going to predict what the next
observation is going to be like in the
tic tac toe board i'm only going to
predict what is the next hidden state
going to be t plus one
t plus one like this is
one this is two this is
three
so you know depending on which action i
do which
which is going what is going to be the
next hidden state of the environment um
sorry of yeah of the environment what's
going to be the next hidden state and
from that hidden state i always going to
predict what's going what's going to be
the reward for transitioning there
what's going to be my own policy which
is a bit
weird that you have to do this but you
have to and which is going which what's
going to be sort of the value and the
value is
what is going to be my future reward
when i go from here
so these are the sort of things that mu
zero predicts and with that it is able
to search this latent tree note the
addition to mu zero sorry yeah the
addition sorry to alpha zero which is
this one right here so we might we might
label this this is something like re in
force
this is alpha zero and this is mu zero
so the difference to alpha zero being
that we no longer have an explicit model
so in order to do tree search we have to
learn a model and the model that mu0
learns is in the latent space purely
right there is it doesn't predict future
observations and it only learns all of
this from
the signal that it so it predicts the
reward it predicts its own policy and it
predicts the future value and those are
the only learning signals for the world
model
that is good because it focuses the
algorithm on what's essential it is
essential to get the maximum reward
possible and therefore the learning the
more the learning signals center around
those concepts the better
but that also means
learning the entire world model just
from signals like the reward is
extremely sparse so it uses a lot of
data
and that is that's essentially the catch
right here
so we're not going to go into you know
how exactly uh mu0
uh does monte carlo research they have a
way of balancing exploration and
exploitation right here by essentially
using an upper confidence bound formula
that you can see right here
but so
efficient zero goes and says there are
three
main weaknesses with mu0
first of all they say lack of
supervision on the environment model
that's what i just said
all the the model the latent model of
the environment is learned purely
from the signals of the end from the
reward signal the value signal these are
single numbers and to ask the model to
learn a transition
function for the environment model is a
big ask and of course needs a lot of
data just from that
the second one is
hardness to deal with alea toric
uncertainty i like i'm i've given up on
trying to remember which one is alea
toric and which one is what's the other
one epistemic i have no idea okay let's
just read the paragraph
the predicted rewards have large
prediction errors
so
if there is uncertainty in the
environment for example the environment
is hard to model the reward prediction
errors will accumulate when expanding
the monte carlo research tree to a large
depth resulting in sub-optimal
performance in
exploration and evaluation so what they
mean is that if i predict if i'm if this
reward right here
has a bit of an error and then i go on
searching right these branches right
here and then the reward i predict right
here also has a bit of an error and so
on and we go down the tree uh and every
reward has a bit of an error what i'll
do in order to uh you know at the end
at the end right here
i have a path and i don't go to the end
i stop after a while and i
add up the rewards that led me here and
that's sort of you know how valuable
this node is plus the value that i
predict right here that's going to be
the
value of this path is going to be the
sum of the rewards
until i'm here plus the value from here
on out
and if all of these little rewards have
little errors on them that quickly adds
up to a big error so that's their second
criticism right here that's something
we're gonna have to solve and thirdly
off policy issues with multi-step value
and that is a general that is a general
um thing in these reinforcement learning
algorithms the more distributed you make
them the more sort of what people
usually do is they have like a learner
box in the middle learn
so there's a neural network there but
then they have a lot of actors
um
actor machines so they distribute
training
and interacting with the environment and
these send back data there's usually a
replay buffer right here somewhere and
that means just that the neural network
that is here at the learner
is not the same that generated the data
because the data is kind of old and
until you use the data to practice the
neural network will have already learned
from other data and therefore you get an
off policy issue even though it's an on
policy algorithm
now mu0 does a little bit to correct
this
but they say this has to be done more
so
how are we going how are they
now now we tackle these these three
things so the first thing they tackle is
this lack of supervision on the
environment model
so what they do is they add a
self-supervised consistency loss you
remember that we map the observation at
time t
to a state a hidden state at time t and
then we use our latent model to predict
for a given action what's the state
going to be at time t plus one
and that's an estimate right now what
this paper says is that wait a minute
if we simply look at what happens in the
real world right observation t plus one
and we send it through the same
so through this
through this same encoding function
then that gives us the hidden state at
time t plus one so technically these two
things here should be equal
so the hidden state at time t plus one
and the estimated hidden state at time t
plus one they should be kind of the same
so what they do is they use a
self-supervised consistency loss uh that
they they nap from simpsium so simpsium
is a contrastive learning framework or
self-supervised learning framework and
it's usually used to
have two images which have been
differently augmented so to make their
representation equal so till the model
learns to sort of ignore the data
augmentation that's how you train
self-supervised image models but here we
don't augment differently what we do is
we take an observation and we take the
observation at time t plus one and the
first observation we actually map it
through that function that is supposed
to give us this estimation of the next
state and then we use a similarity loss
in order to pull those two things
together so
this function that gives us the next
state and the representation functions
they're now going to be trained in order
to make those two things the next hidden
state and the estimation of the next
hidden state similar to each other in
fact the the left branch right here is
the one that's trained but that includes
the representation function and the next
state function
so you might you might ask
you know
this is kind of the first question that
everyone in mu zero has is like why is
this not done because this is if you
look at the loss of mu0 you can pretty
easily see that that is possible and i
think the mu0 authors have deliberately
not introduced a loss like this because
they say no if we learn
from just the reward signals that is
going to be a better algorithm even
though you know it might use more data
but at the end it really trains for what
is important for what is the end goal
and that's why they didn't introduce a
loss like this
introducing a loss like this clearly uh
trades off uh the what's the actual
target is namely optimizing the reward
right
we actually don't care if anything's
consistent we simply want a higher
reward so it trades that off for sample
efficiency because now the supervision
signal here is much much larger because
now we work with
different hidden states which are entire
vectors so
that's going to be about much better
signal
so that's the first improvement the
second improvement is what they say
end-to-end prediction of the value
prefix
so they make an example right here of
saying okay what's what's the value you
know if you if you look at this you have
to predict sort of the future value can
you really predict what's it going to be
like either the green player let's say
the ball flies in this direction the
green player is going to catch the ball
or not right and that makes a huge
difference now you as a human at this
point you
know that it's not going to the green
player is not going to catch that ball
um and at this time you're kind of sure
uh but it's quite hard to predict at
this time right here and
it's even harder to predict um
when you know at which step in time that
player is going to miss the ball and
that's an argument they make for for
essentially saying if we add up the
rewards of our own predictions
they can introduce a lot of mistakes and
but that's exactly what we do if we look
at the q value that we use in this tree
search what we do is we add up the
rewards that we got in the path so far
and we add the value at that particular
path and that is very error prone
because this sum right here accumulates
all the little errors that uh
that that happen in in prediction and
you know as i said if if we're not
exactly sure at which point
um
that is just one of the examples to show
you how hard this problem is of
predicting rewards step by step if you
look into the future
so what they do is is pretty simple
they say instead of adding up all the
rewards
k steps into the future what if we
simply take the hidden states that we
predict k steps into the future and just
shove them into a neural network
and then that neural network will output
the sum of the rewards so instead of
summing the rewards directly we have a
neural network output the total sum much
like we have a neural network that
outputs the value function uh at that
looks ahead this neural network right
here it will look sort of back it will
look into the past from the current
state to the state the end state that we
rolled out in imagination it'll predict
the entire value they're using lstm for
that because it can take in arbitrary
number of states and the lstm has a per
step rich supervision because we have a
reward at each step and therefore they
say that works quite well so that's the
second thing the third thing is
the model based off policy correction
so
um
yeah this one this one is a little bit
more tricky but essentially
we can
see where is it okay we can read a bit
through it to see what it does this is
an off policy correction mechanism and
uh they have two different
mechanisms to do of policy correction i
already said of policy correction you
have to do it because the data that you
get to learn from comes from your replay
buffer comes from delay from the network
and so on and is a little bit older than
the network that you're learning and
that turns out to be quite a big problem
so um
what we usually do is we sample a
trajectory from the replay buffer and we
compute and we compute this uh target
value z right here for the value
function
the value target sums from off paul
sorry suffers from off policy issues
since the trajectory is rolled out using
an older policy and thus the value
target is no longer accurate now mu0
re-analyzed this is a particular version
of mu0 already handles that a little bit
in that it actually recomputes the
values the scalar values with the
current network before it learns from
them but still the policy used to
generate that data is from an old policy
and so they say
when data is limited we have to reuse
the data sampled from a much older
policy thus exaggerating the inaccurate
value target
issue
so what they do is they say well instead
of using instead of using sort of the
path so we're
this is the state right and here is what
actually happened right we took some
actions that's what actually happened
and now what we would like to do is we
would like to take this and learn from
it
but
the policy used to generate that path is
an old policy so the current network
might have done something entirely
different it might have done a different
action right here and got to a different
point and that is a problem because
in an own policy method we'd largely
like to learn from
actions that have been generated with
the current policy
so what they say is that
we're simply going to not use the entire
trajectory for learning but we're going
to cut off at some point because of
course the further out the more
uncertain we get and that cut-off point
is going to be closer the older the
trajectory is so for a very recent
trajectory might cut off towards the end
but for a very old trajectory we went
cut off like all the way here and then
what we do after the cut-off point is so
we take this we cut it off at some point
we say well it's old but you know this
part right here is still
sort of
the uncertainty is
is
not large enough for us to worry so much
and then what they do is they use
because they have a latent model for for
the and for the world they use that
model to imagine a rollout
so much like something like dreamer or
so they now
train using imaginary rollouts from the
point where they cut off so the
the trajectories in the replay buffer
are more like seed values
and after that they imagine rollouts
using their latent model of the world
all right so
yeah so
i think that's it
um
we redo an mcts search with the current
policy on the last state and compute the
empirical mean value oh yeah so at the
last so at the last node right here they
redo an mcts search they uh in order to
get a really good target value there
with the current policy
yep that's that's it
okay so these are the three improvements
again they introduce a consistency loss
on the hidden states uh to make their
transition model better
second they directly predict the um
value what they call value prefix this
thing right here instead of summing up
the rewards as they go along the tree
search
and thirdly they
seed they use the
collector trajectories as seed values
and then train essentially um in half
imagined uh half imagined rollouts with
the current policy
so that's it so what does that give them
it gives them very good performance on
this atari 100k benchmark they do some
additional um
they do some additional
things right here additional ablation
studies for example they try to
reconstruct
the
observation from the hidden state and
they see that for example if you don't
have a consistency loss
this quickly fails so this would be the
original mu zero whereas with the
consistency loss you can see that kind
of sort of there is and you know there
is something right there uh that looks
like the observation now here i don't
know if that is after the 100k steps
because of course mu0 after 100k steps
also doesn't perform super duper well uh
and therefore you wouldn't be surprised
like that this is or it could be because
their reconstruction method is just kind
of poor as well but the difference is
noticeable between the two models the
one that has the consistency loss and
the one that it doesn't
they also analyze for example
the validation loss
if you have if you directly predict the
rewards or if you use this value prefix
prediction method you can see during
training it's approximately the same
however at validation time this loss is
much much lower and lastly lastly
well they do a lot of ablations that is
it what i
was surprised or not surprised what i
noticed in the ablations and this is
pretty much in all the ablations there
is no consistent ranking so they have
three improvements right here
and sometimes uh
this improvement right here for example
will be the most valuable so you can see
that without the value prefix alien
drops quite a bit
and in other times you can see right
here this one will be the most valuable
and yet in other times some some other
one like the last one will be the most
valuable don't see one right now but i
have i've looked at it and
that there is no
consistent thing so that
it means that there's not a single
recipe to make this thing better it's a
conglomeration and for different atari
games different things are important and
that sort of leads you
to think you know
is this
this isn't a this isn't a method from
let's say principle this is they have
looked
at what fails and they have fixed
essentially one by one the major
mistakes that they found and that is
that is a way to go about it but it is
also a danger that we sort of over
engineer to the benchmarks that we have
because
you know clearly if i just put one of
these improvements then some of the
atari games will improve by a lot but
others won't and that
to me is a little bit
of of the of the danger right here and
this is why i'm not you know like i
can't i can't tell you
if this algorithm is going to be
a staple algorithm for sample efficient
rl
or if it just works particularly well on
this benchmark they do do another
benchmark they do do the um
deepmind control a benchmark but i think
there's going to be more evaluation
needed
but yeah i'm excited it really has the
potential uh to be something something
cool all right that was it from me uh
thank you so much for listening watching
let me know what you think in the
comments and bye bye